hey there good morning we have reports
of several injuries the injury is
serious enough to bring out the fatal
team and here's the impact to traffic we
have this big rig here with an oversized
load trying to get through off to the
right actually to the left we can see uh
nhp here and the scene of the crash is
right at the intersection we have one
car on a median that's charleston and
then a second car right in front of it
the crash happening here at the
intersection lamb in charleston where
right now fatal investigators are taking
over the investigation this is video
from earlier this morning and this is
happening just as local authorities are
reporting an alarming number of vehicle
fatalities fatalities this year over the
weekend the valley reached a grand
milestone reaching a hundred roadway
fatalities or surpassing that number
actually so far in the year with metro
police recording a hundred two deaths
compared to 101 for all of 2020 we're
still uh we still have more than three
months left this year and out here you
can see
the big rig is getting through at the
intersection it looks like it will go
around the debris that's at the
intersection for the crash as traffic is
trying to get through and again want to
remind you guys that the entire
intersection charleston and lamb is
closed this big rig though is going
around the scene of the crash that's the
very latest from out here we'll have an
update in less than 30 minutes for now
reporting live hector mejia live local
now let's send it over to nate
thank you hector so as hector reported
some cars are getting around that
intersection by using parking lots we'll
talk more about in a second stop on the
i-15 lanes are open you're just slowing
down they're approaching the sahara area
we'll talk about the northbound side of
the 95 515 after we show you here's that
purple closure indicating lamb closed
from stuart all the way down towards
sahara a live picture of the
intersection of stuart and lamb folks
are getting through there but having to
work their way around so within with
this intersection closed we're
suggesting you go north to stuart for
east west travel because you can't get
through at charleston or south to sahara
and with north south lamb closed we're
suggesting you head over towards nellis
we'll continue to keep an eye on all the
freeways in fact here is that closure on
this those two lanes only for the north
and south on 95 515 between the
spaghetti bowl and eastern